what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime or bro and with demon slayer's
second season in full swing now we
thought it was the right time to drop
some facts about our boy tonjiro camado
tanjiro is the main protagonist of the
demon slayer series who became a demon
slayer in the demon slayer corpse to
find a remedy for his sister neziko to
turn her back into a human our boy hunts
down and kills demons to protect those
in need of protection and has even vowed
to take down the demon king of pop
himself muzan now for those of you who
know me from my channel you'll know that
i cover character facts on a lot of
different anime series and it's time to
bring that energy over here as i bring
you the top 10 facts you probably didn't
know about tanjuro and if you'd like to
see more demon slayer character facts
here on anime uproar make sure to let
the boys know by channeling the demon
slayer within and smashing that like
button let us know in the comment
section below as well what other demon
slayer characters you'd like to see us
cover now if you haven't already make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit the notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demon slayer videos and whilst you wait
for more demon slayer content to drop
make sure to check out our giant and
ever-growing demon slayer playlist that
covers videos on all the harshera demon
moons breathing styles and much more
link to that is in the description so
without further ado
let's get to it
[Music]
okay let's kick this thing off with
tonjiro's name's meanings the first
kanji in his name is the kanji for
charcoal which is interesting because
prior to the horrendous incident of his
family's murder nezuko being turned into
a demon and him setting off to become a
demon slayer tonjero was a coal burner
who would travel to the village at the
bottom of the mountain to sell said coal
the other kanji used in his name mean to
heal which again is a really good
reference to tanjuro's super caring
nature the way he wants to protect those
around him and to make sure that no one
has to suffer the same way he and his
family have not only that but tanjiro's
main goal is to find a way of turning
nezuko back into a human which in the
case of this kanji is a reference as to
how tonjiro wants to heal his little
sister now the last kanji means sun or
male which is a very common masculine
name suffix in japan also the second
character in his name is said to refer
to the exorcism of demons and i just
love it when the names of characters are
thought out like this and i always find
matching up the meanings to the
characters really really interesting so
as for his surname kamado the first
kanji when translated is the japanese
word for a traditional japanese wood or
a furnace fueled again by charcoal this
second kanji simply means door now i'm
sure i'm not alone in thinking that
tonjiro camado isn't the hardest name to
remember but for in no skate it
certainly is as tonjiro has been
incorrectly dubbed many times by him
with efforts including gompachiro
kamaboko tontaro itadaki conjuro anago
mongero santoro ponjaro and many many
more you've gotta love a nose game for
this it's uh it's comical you love to
see it you really do
[Music]
okay let's talk popularity there are two
demon slayer popularity polls where the
fans would vote for their favorite
characters and the results from both
make for some pretty interesting reading
in the first demon slayer popularity
poll tangero actually took first place
with 6742
votes edging out second place zenitsu
who had
4299 votes and neziko taking third place
with 3
319 votes i thought this was pretty
surprising as my money would have been
on nezuko bringing home the gold i was
in tokyo a couple of years ago and you
know the love nezuko had over there was
just insane well demon slayer is a whole
to be honest but when it came to you
know the prices on character merch or a
certain character being sold out it was
always nezuko saying that the first poll
was before the series gained its anime
adaptation and you know with it it's
stardom so it does make sense when you
think about it that way as for the
second popularity poll tangero took
fourth place with
9045 votes sandwiched between rengoku in
fifth who had eight thousand votes and
third place muitrio with 11
948 votes interestingly it was our boy
zenitsu taking top spot with an amazing
17
451 votes and giu taking the silver with
an impressive 13 281
for fact number three let's focus on
some of tonjiro's physical stats so our
boy tangero stands at 165 centimeters or
five foot five which going off of the
heights of the other characters in the
show is about average tangero is the
tallest when it comes to comparing him
against zenetsu and inosuke but if we
throw the hashera into the equation two
he is just a little shorter than my my
personal best girl of the series beat
story can we get some love for for me
sorry please in the comments yes
easily best girl
don't have me anyway as for weight
tangero weighs 61 kilograms or 134
pounds weighing more than zenitsu but
less than a nosuke because in this case
just freaking tanked man like
damn
tonjiro is 15 years of age by the end of
chapter 5 of the manga which is around
the time he takes place in final
selection he is the same age as inosuke
but a year younger than both zenitsu and
kanau at 16. by the end of the manga he
is somewhere between 16 and 17 years of
age now tanjiro's birthday is on july
14th which makes him a cancer and when
it comes to you know his zodiac sign and
the characteristics one would have for
being a cancer it does match up pretty
well with him tondero is a very
compassionate sweet and deeply feeling
character who is someone you can rely on
when you're going through the harder
times in your life and it's not a hard
one to like think of it you know how
many times have we seen tundra reach out
and put others before himself throughout
the series and i'm not just talking
about for people in his inner circle
tantro has done this for complete
strangers
i find that there are two types of
people when it comes to this subject you
know people that are mourning people and
those who really aren't where am i going
with this i can hear you ask i can hear
you ask well did you know that tonjiro
is a morning person and is the second
best at waking up in the morning out of
the demon slayer characters when goku to
no surprise takes first place so tanjuro
will even wake up at the time that he
intends to wake up or he will wake from
his sleep instantly if someone says
anything to him now sticking on the
topic of sleeping tonjiro tends to dream
about either battle or training he's
constantly analyzing himself even when
he's not awake as he dreams about what
didn't go well in a previous fight as
well as what he could improve on not
just in battle but when it comes to his
own training too and it is said that if
we were able to peek into one of
tanjuro's dreams that they would feel
clear and realistic
because i i i tend to forget mine as
soon as i wake up like i'll remember
like little bits
but i forget like the main the main
thing that's going on am i alone that
let let us know in the comment section
okay for this one let's take a look at
some of the information that the data
book gives us about tangero or data data
data data i don't know how americans say
it or canadians sorry canadians i don't
know so first of all tonjiro's favorite
food is angelica sprouse when these are
served up on the table no matter how
composed our boy is if you look closely
at him you can see his nostrils flaring
and on the topic of his nostrils
tonjiro's keen sense of smell made the
people of the village near the camado
residents often ask him for help when it
came to finding missing people which
leads on to this one here the second fan
book you know focused on a particular
quote tanjaro said and gave more context
to it which was pretty pretty
fascinating to be fair and you'll you'll
see how it ties in now as we know
tanjuro is certainly one for words be
them inspirational emotional or just
simple words of encouragement the
particular quote the fanbook focuses on
was whenever happiness is destroyed
there is also a scent of blood now the
reason tonjiro said this was explained
in the book by telling us that it was
tonjero that found his father coughing
up blood and dying he was also the one
who found his grandmother dying as well
as that he smelt the blood of a dying
person from the village we had
previously mentioned and informed the
people there if it wasn't for tonjero
the family of that person would not have
realized that they were dying it's crazy
that sense of smell
second to none second to none
next up let's talk about tonjiro's
nichiren blade so nichiren swords are
special blades used by demon slayers in
the corpse and are unique to that
particular demon slayer neutrine swords
will take on a specific colour when it
is first wielded by its owner however
the owner is required to have a certain
amount of skill or the blade will not
change color for tangero the blade
changes to a black colour which are not
very well known about and because of
this they are considered as a bad omen
meaning that the wilder will not go far
as they usually die much before anything
can be learned about that blade however
in tonjiro's case the sword turning
black is a symbol of his ability to use
the hinokami kagura or
sun breathing i guess i should say and
the only other known wielder of a black
nichiren blade is none other than urichi
now the only other thing to mention
about his sword is the appearance
specifically it's hilt so tanjuro's
original hill was a black wheel however
after the tragic death of rengoku
tanjuro is given his flame hill that is
in the shape of a flame with a red core
and orange outer tonjero uses this hilt
on his blade after the sword smith
village arc and just to add tanjaro is
actually one of very very few characters
in demon slayer to have their nichiren
sword change in appearance
[Music]
[Applause]
tanjaro's japanese voice actor is
natsuki hanai hanai is currently 30
years of age born june 26th of 1991. he
originally entered the workforce whilst
he was still in high school and he
thought long and hard about his career
but had always planned to one day become
a voice actor to which he did in
november of 2009 when he joined across
entertainment fun fact about him here he
started uploading let's play videos on
youtube in march 2019 and gained over
500 000 subscribers in just seven months
it's that's it insane anyway he's also
had a pretty successful career voice
acting he actually won the best rookie
of the year award at the ninth seiyu
awards and has had some impressive roles
such as ken kaneki in tokyo ghoul takumi
aldini from food wars kusey arima in
your lion april and many more
tundras english voice actor is jack
aguilar he was born in february of 1998
and is currently 23 years of age now he
is an american voice actor but also has
talents galore elsewhere as he is a very
good pianist a martial artist as well as
being a singer on the side now again he
has had some pretty impressive roles
which include his first major role as
genos in one punch man he has also
voiced arthur pendragon from the seven
deadly sins no that's a big hit on this
channel otto in re zero and many many
more now interestingly both of tonjero's
voice actors have also voiced sieg from
fate apocrypha
[Music]
okay final fact we're gonna do a
lightning round where i'll fit as many
other facts as i can into this one and
uh as we're talking about tundra let's
call this one the hinokami kagura aka
the dance of the fire facts
i came up with that one myself
right let's go so tanjuro's signature
headbutt move was inherited from his
mother who also had a hard forehead mr
nice guy tanjuro was actually dubbed as
the most polite character in the entire
series tonjero is actually the vocalist
of a band called stylish scruffy
democracy the band also had zenitsu on
the xiaomi sen and as the band's
songwriter inosuke on the taiko drums
and tengen on harmonica now the band's
debut single was called exploding skin
and the melancholy of modern smell which
didn't go down too well as everyone who
heard the song felt dizzy and would
begin to vomit non-stop after hearing it
and to go with the last fact there did
you know that tonjiro is actually tone
deaf and you know it makes me wonder did
that have a part to play in that song
being so bad tonjero is certainly not a
good liar as he cannot keep a straight
face due to his very honest nature when
lying it is said that tonjiro can
actually understand what birds are
saying to him and finally in a time
before text messages and emails tonjiro
had pen pals who were sakonji and
senjiro from the entertainment district
the sound hashrat tengen and the water
hasherat giyu though
giu would never actually write back to
him
no surprise
and that is it for our boy tanjuro i
hope you learned something new or at
least enjoyed revisiting the facts we
showcased on the show's protagonist if
you did enjoy this video remember to let
the boys know by smashing the like
button and if you want to see more demon
slayer character facts on the channel
let us know who you are most desperate
to see in the comment section below if
you haven't already make this the video
you subscribe and hit the notification
bell to turn on all notifications or you
will miss future demon slayer videos and
while you wait for more demon slayer
content to drop make sure to check out
our giant and ever growing demon slayer
playlist that covers videos on all the
hashra demon moons breathing styles and
much more link to that is in the
description and i especially want to
thank the patreon squad over on patreon
and here on youtube who help make videos
like this one possible first and
foremost i want to thank the patreon
alleged the one acknowledged by lord
twigo himself alpha sigma and kyle
salisbury and are the one-tier patrons
the ones who stand on top of all clans
ingrata al jatel pate hether the
red-haired fox hero carbine water the
toasted chee cory mcgowan the spike
eight two two seven lonely dakar dylan
isadore spidey life to nell tungsten
tarkis baked buddhist jeremy cummings
and che whitley and our pro hero
patreons the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz very gucci alicia
akhtar bonnie parks joanne garcia fat
boy games kaido might be a duck jessica
rabbit jeremy phillips alivenier temple
king matthew and demetrius water thank
you all so much if you do enjoy our work
you can support more of it by going over
to patreon.com forward slash animeopro
and become a patreon today for as little
as one dollar if you do so you will get
your name featured in future videos
amongst these absolute legends right
here and you'll also get access to our
patreon only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course dank memes so
check out patreon.com forward slash
anime or brawl link in the description
if you're interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button right next to the
subscribe button that you've already
hopefully destroyed so that you can
support more content that way if you
prefer whichever way you choose to
support us you'll get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you